[Musique]
la nature est une beauté fragile trop
souvent négligée c'est pour mieux la
protéger que le département a créé les
ems les espaces naturels sensibles
depuis douze ans les week-ends de la
nature offre au public l'occasion de
découvrir ces sites sur toute l'île à
cilaos 2 il est sont mises à l'honneur
cette année
l'islet chico et lille est des trois
salazes
[Musique]
allez savez-vous un bon petit réchauffer
à la table des waro on ne déroge pas à
la tradition a réchauffé pour accueillir
les visiteurs et les premières lueurs du
jour
c'est à cilaos sur l'îlet chico que
c'est établi la famille de pascal vous
avez du ve et il apporte comme ça c'est
pour lutter contre l'érosion ça dure le
sol
ils portent pas grave une histoire à
l'occasion des week-ends de la nature le
propriétaire partage son quotidien il
son savoir avec un groupe de visiteurs à
chico c'est l'état de mes anciens
jusqu'aux veille à auch coup de bois si
l'on avait déjà aussi il ya un vieux
personnages
d'accord c'est à dire le vieux
personnages qui habitait ici d'accord ça
pas saper les rafales shiko shiko fils
et petit-fils de tisanes heures c'est
tout naturellement que la visite de
pascal porte sur les plantes médicinales
et la permaculture voit bien que
j'associe par exemple c'est rogner
d'accord la connaissiez un goyaviers ça
se peut alors une on a tendance à tout
mettre profs les profs dessous c'est
joli c'est renoncer une mauvaise idée
après les explications place à l'atelier
pratique on voit roma donc pas en
pariant pas d'accord que c'est une
maison résistant d'abord offert le
travail du paillage et c'est de nouveau
le vétiver qui va fournir la matière
première on entend mettre les pieds à
l'envers pour une fois que le toit est
monté un aspect comme ça c'est bien
rigide il n'y a pas de fuite
petits ou grands chacun retiendra de
cette visite des enseignements
enrichissant disons que vaut mieux
laisser faire la nature plutôt que
d'essayer de absolument vouloir la
contrôler pourtant essayé de d'apprendre
à connaître les cadeaux qu'elle veut
bien nous faire
c'est important parce que va dire qu on
joue on va pouvoir on peut s'enrichir et
en même temps
enfin on peut essayer d'améliorer cette
île qui est magnifique tout près de là
sur le deuxième il est de cilaos
c'est nathalie qui nous fait découvrir
son univers bien là en face de nous on
est dans le piton des neiges
il ya le grand monde les trois salazes
la tête de plus tôt la tête de chien et
le col du tas vite ils ont entre les
deux mois mon grand père ça serait sa
petite parcelle elle faisait des la
plantation petits pois haricots sa
famille à elle a vécu ici sur l'île est
des trois salazes anciens propriétaires
étaient après un religieux qui a acheté
le terrain dans les années 60
après il a mis des colons pour
travailler son terrain et mon papa il
était le dernier chrono à travailler
pour ce monsieur comme tes petits contes
et montrent notre papa tu es là tu
regardes à loudun sentiers fashanu web
parmi les visiteurs françois fait le
plein de connaissances
apparemment le plus il fait de bonnes
racines alors si j'ai bien compris oui
et l'ubs ont l'une bois moins 1000
litres d'eau il est venue de sainte
marie avec sa famille
bon on passe pour aller de silas à
mafate par le col du taïbit ça fait deux
fois qu'on reperd ce il est les deux
trois salazes pour le coup un thé
vraiment heureux que cette sortie sera
organisée sur une île est des trois
salades
du coup c'est génial de causer de la
prends plein de choses mais sur la vie
du village comment commence et il était
né comment les terres ont été attribués
on ne connaissait pas tous à tout toute
l'histoire de l'île est alors on
connaissait pas quoi ces deux îles est
sont en partie géré par le département
classé ems espaces naturels sensibles
c'est pour promouvoir ses sites que la
collectivité organise chaque année les
week-ends de la nature on a envie que
les gens aillent dans ce milieu naturel
pour qu'ils fassent connaissance avec
leur propre environnement
avec la richesse de la biodiversité
qu'ils ont autour d'eux parce que la
réunion fait partie des 34 spot de la
biodiversité et c'est vrai que c'est
important aujourd'hui de dire nous avons
une île qui est classée au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
il faut prendre soin de tous les
éléments environnementaux que nous
vautour de national en bavent il en bave
il est super bon pour la peau problème
de petits boutons acné eczéma et
rentrent aussi un volet éco touristique
à développer et donc ce volet côte
touristique c'est quoi c'est donc la
proche de sensibilisation du site à
travers la découverte des plantes
endémiques des plantes médicinales et il
trouvait aussi une certaine convivialité
à travers un repas ou après ou
simplement à travers un simple couchage
une nuit et alors que les sauts mais
s'estompe la convivialité s'invite bel
et bien au coin du feu
[Musique]
c'est en musique que les visiteurs
achèvent leur journée des étoiles plein
les yeux
[Musique]
les week-ends de la nature ont pour
objectif de promouvoir les espaces
naturels sensibles de la réunion à
travers des visites des ateliers et des
rencontres cette année
la 13ème édition se tient du 7 au 29
octobre 22 sites sont à découvrir
partout sur l'île
pour consulter le programme ou faire des
réservations vous pouvez consulter les
sites du département ou appeler le 02
100 62 97 59 59
[Musique]